Hồi đô lần đơn của anh với trình kến 2 của biểu tình lớn nhất,
liên quan đến chính xác nhập cửa thu hút hàng chục nghiên người tham gia,
khoảng 1 chân người nghiên người trong phòng trang thống nhất nước anh đã xuất đơn phản đối nhất cửa
tâm nên một chân những của tổn hàng kánh thơ ố lớn nhất chúng mình sự hiện đại.
Cùng thời điểm khoảng 5 năm nghiên người tập hơn gần đó để uống nè cửa,
hình định tộng đồng ngày đóng phải trọng tích cửa trở sáu ý.
Bây giờ anh nhóm biểu tình tập chung cân nhau,
khiến huy cơ xuống đột tăng cao,
một kánh xác lôn đơn về chiểm khai lực lượng đông.
Sự dụng người nghi vụ và công cuộc kìm xác đông,
khai lực lượng trên năng,
một số nhóm biểu tình quá khách đẹp có hành động tấn tình tình xác bằng chế lọt,
pháo xãnh và đấm đá,
kính tình gình trình trình thăng khăn.
Đà cối nhất chính người đi bắt sự ở bánh nhiều các buộc ăn nhau,
rồi trình gánh báo sẽ thiết một các biển pháp ăn ninh nhìn ngạch,
nhắm nhanh chẳng bạo lực leo thang,
tư những cuộc biểu tình tương tự trọng tương lai.